Salut à tous et bienvenue dans l'astuce du mercredi
Comme tous les mercredis je vous donne une astuce de mentalisme sur un domaine particulier
ou sur un truc à faire avec votre cerveau, rapide à apprendre, rapide à mettre en place.
Je me suis aperçu que ça faisait très longtemps que je ne vous avait pas donné une petite astuce de maths
comme ça qu'on déconne un peu. Parce qu'on déconne grave avec les maths sur cette chaine
Alors aujourd'hui je vous apprends à faire une multiplication, une grosse multiplication très facilement avec un papier un crayon
Et l'opération la plus dure que vous auriez à faire ce serai 9x9
Et même pour une opération comme 9x9 si jamais vous avez un doute je vous avait fait une astuce là-dessus je vais vous mettre une fiche là-haut elle va apparaître.
Je vais vous montrer la méthode de la diagonale
Comme son nom l'indique l'idée est de construire des diagonales.
alors pour ça on va représenter les chiffres
imaginons 12x12
C'est un exemple très simple pour que vous puissiez comprendre la méthode
J'écris le premier 12 et je trace des lignes au niveau de chaque chiffre
j'écris le deuxième 12 perpendiculairement
et je trace encore une fois des lignes au niveau de chaque chiffre et comme ça toutes les lignes forment des colonnes et des lignes qui se croisent.
au niveau de chaque carré je vais construire des diagonales dans chaque case
une fois qu'on a fait ça, la méthode consiste à multiplier chaque chiffre par le chiffre en face
donc 1x2, 1x1 et ici 2x2 et 2x1
et de reporter le résultat dans les cases en utilisant les deux parties de diagonales
je vous fait voir c'est beaucoup plus simple une fois qu'on la vu
1x2 ça fait 2 donc j'écris 02. 02 parce que je suis obligé d'utiliser cette partie.
1x1 ça fait 1 donc j'écris 01
je passe ici
2x2 ça fait 4 donc 04 et 2x1 ça fait 2 donc 02
une fois qu'on a rempli entièrement le tableau, il faut maintenant reporter ce qu'il y a à l’intérieur de chaque diagonale
ici on à 4 diagonales, la première, la deuxième, la troisième et la quatrième.
dans la première il y a 4, je mets 4.
quand il y a plusieurs chiffres il faut tous les additionner entre eux. 2+0+2 ça nous fait 4
dans la troisième, 0+1+0 ça nous fait 1
et dans la quatrième il y a 0 donc ça ne compte pas. Le résultat de 12x12 c'est bien 144
Je vous fait une deuxième exemple maintenant un petit peu plus costaud pour que vous puissiez bien comprendre la méthode, elle est hyper pratique.
Aujourd'hui on est le combien? On est le 26/04. Je vais mettre 2604x2016
Ça c'est du balèze.
Alors d'abord j'écris mon 2604 et je trace mes colonnes.
sur le coté j'écris mon 2016 et je trace les lignes.
Souvenez-vous, maintenant qu'on a fait ça il faut maintenant tracer les diagonales
Et à partir de maintenant c'est du remplissage avec les multiplications simple.
2x4 ça fait 8
deux fois 0 ça fait zéro
deux fois 6 ça fait 12 donc vous
avez vu j'ai mis les dizaines ici et les unités là
deux fois 2 ça nous fait 4
On passe à la deuxième ligne, ça va nous faire 0 partout  puisque 0x0 ça fait 0
et 6x2 fois de qui nous font 12
on a rempli tous le tableau il faut maintenant remporter la somme de chaque diagonale
aussi simplement que ça. Première
diagonale
à l'intérieur on a quatre
deuxième diagonale à l'intérieur n'a que
quatre cinq six
troisième diagonale à l'intérieur on a six
Quatrième diagonale, à l'intérieur on a 8 et(+)2=10 et(+) 6=16 et(+) 3=19
Donc je mets juste 9 et je retient 1
1 et(+)2=3 et(+)1=4 pour cette diagonale là.
diagonale suivante on à que 2 donc 2
et diagonale suivant à l'intérieur on à 5 donc 5
ce qui nous fait
5 249 664, le résultat de 2604x2016
On avait parlé ensemble de cette astuce dans les commentaires il y a quelque semaine
donc je me suis dit c'était plutôt cool de vous faire une vidéo ce serait beaucoup plus clair à comprendre
j'espère aussi que ça pourra vous servir
un jour un moment donné que vous serez en galère,
vous avez un gros calcul, une grosse
multiplication vous vous ferez: héee ! il y a la technique des diagonales
si les astuces du mercredi vous plaisent, n'oubliez pas de qu'en plus le samedi il y a les master class, c'est beaucoup plus consistant et c'est toujours à base de mentalisme
Si cette vidéo vous a plu et si ce style de vidéo vous plaisent vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissaint un .... excusez-moi
ca doit être juste ici, voilà c'est un... POUCE EN L'AIR
Merci à vous tous d'être là et de suivre la chaine
Merci beaucoup à ceux qui soustitrent ces vidéos
Et si vous venez juste d'arriver suite à un partage n'hésiter pas à vous abonner
le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez-vous demain à 17h pour une nouvelle vidéo
CIAOOO